okay so this is up a tree the incredibly
epic episode I can't believe nobody
talks up I mean like the think
cliffhanger or that I remember you you
know or the legend that they always talk
about that but no up a tree this episode
blew my mind in how giant and epic a
tree is yeah
this has really enlightened me as to the
workings of the inside of a tree but
basically what it is is a tree part of
the tree yes I will never forget that
everything goes did they ever do we ever
see why everything was green in there no
Lucy I don't remember to be honest hmm
but no I'm ever being green by just
cause I can't do they have a reason I
don't know if I missed it yeah talk
about the comments I'm sure you already
have already so yeah so if Finn and Jake
they're just playing frisbee and
Rainicorn is very pointless
the more you think about I guess we just
want to see how her bump is doing and
they climb and frisbee goes up a tree
and Finn decides he wants to climb up it
and he doesn't want Jake's help
you know sometimes man needs to get his
disk back so these animals seem to kind
of be helping him but then it turns out
they're trying to either get rid of him
or trap him forever he finds out they
try to trap him forever but he befriends
a squirrel a quote-unquote flying
squirrel and he just walks through the
bars which is great I love that joke
because okay grown a week rug with like
similar cartoon shows didn't you hate it
particularly like in the 80s and early
90s cartoons when the bars were so huge
and they're like get me out of here like
just turn to the left and slip out and
sometimes you have to turn yeah so I
really love the acknowledge to that and
he gets on the squirrel and they jump
out and he thinks he can fly but he
really can't because there's none
actually flying yes but then the frisbee
comes with just just flying like a
glider or playing or something and the
perfect throw yeah just the perfect
throw I guess and wait do we know who
threw it yeah he throwed yeah
okay so he throws that it just so
happened to be the perfect throw and
they fly into the sunset and it's don't
forget to take with his ice cream
pickles
yeah and Jake made ice cream pickles
presumably for Rainicorn but I don't
know I could see him almost eating that
too just for fun and they just fly into
the sunset which I remember watching I'm
like an end there just end right there's
something about that end it just seems
so perfect like is this I guess again it
felt very much like the there's got a
name for these like the ones that are
that seemed mostly just goofy like they
got to connect to a story or anything
bigger there and alone I guess so I mean
but it's like this ones are more serious
that can can't be standalone too but are
they seem very much like a Ren Stimpy
episode like hey this is just silly
stupid fun it doesn't have to tie
together at the end it can just end at a
random moment and you know it's like a
delightful waste of time
oh did I go there life a waste of time d
wot droite don't let that become a thing
if that's a terrible word no that's
awesome to watch what sounds cling on
the what if I spoke Klingon which I
don't but yeah it is a fun episode I
said I don't speak Klingon or is that
why I'm a loser
no because you do speak Klingon I know
you do so is to what tell me that you've
do want is a word I'm actually betting
it might be a word it just sounds like a
Klingon word and they make up all sorts
of crap okay so but this episode
can I get distracted too easily um I
mean yeah it was fun I like seeing the
snail again just knowing he got out okay
after Phoenix s by the Lich okay here's
a question
maybe you'll know or maybe you won't
after the snail got possessed by the
Lich do you keep seeing him in every
single episode is it the same pose or as
eyes glowing or something um it's always
the same pose and it's never really
close up enough where you get to see his
eyes okay kind of hidden okay but yeah
and again this one's easy to spot he's
just right there waiting it's like oh
he's okay that's let me feel good but
yeah it was just a fun cute episode
I love the although where's the shirt
just says owl and ya know I liked it
that all that was Pete Jim Cummings
income that's it
sorry only thing I miss Pete or the mask
from splatterhouse my favorite I
disconnects to nothing I know big shock
but they were playing Final Fantasy like
the redone version whatever and there's
a character on there and I said is that
Rob Paulsen he's like I don't know javi
got stabbed like he always checks he
goes yeah he's like apparently this
guy's done a lot of stuff did you know
he was on Ninja Turtles and Animaniacs
I'm like I think so yeah I didn't know
he did video games so I don't think that
we did anything just like he's he's
Raphael and Donatello how is that
possible
and apparently I watched all of these in
somehow I never canal Canaries like what
the most distinct points but but I hit
upon Pete for some strange reason yeah
no he's he's also why the poo - he's a
million voices those two are our
childhoods pretty much like that and
Chesapeake Neal and that's it they like
our childhood and nobody else so some of
our childhood cartoons one thing I did
love about this episode what's the
porcupine and a lot of the other things
that did happen well the porcupine comes
down he's like sit on me the shock will
make you go up higher and he's like I
don't think that's how sorry
goddamnit that's like what the third
time - I've had these feelings I should
know better if I continue he's like in
fitness just like no I don't think
that's how it works he's like no sit on
me
I mean I'm gonna help you sit on me and
he forces himself on Finn
I love Finn scream oh I can't do it yeah
I mean it's but it's great because you
don't cuz in cartoons especially ours
they would go flying up really really
yeah and your cow wondering like well
are they gonna do that cuz this is got
the world room anything can happen so
it's like I I don't know is that the way
this kind of world works um and again
it's one of the fun things about the
show is that you're constantly finding
out how it works I also loved where uh
Finn throws to disk what is hole
his massive throw and he's like Jake's
like I'll be the dog I'll be the human
I'm the human yeah foreign far no talk
doc no it's Park Park Oh
bark bark bark it's like hello I'm a
human yeah well I make you I love that
but when he does the throw finally and
it lands up top Jake goes up and is like
oh kind of reason it's like it's up here
oh that's okay I'll get it you sure it's
right here no sometimes a man's gotta
get zoned disc and then I love that
Jake's just like oh I also I mean again
we talked about this a million times but
I love how even with the you know the
porcupine with whatever the two spikes
are you know is about it he pulls him
out he serves climbing is like see you
did help it's like it I just love
everything's just so upbeat of playful
with them and I love like you know he's
jumping on the branches he's like do we
do we don't use make a little sound
effect with them so yeah I mean that
kind of stuff it's just it's those
little touches that you don't think
would add much but when all comes
together with you know such good
characters it's like sometimes the most
likable things yeah you know just those
little touches can really just make a
character seem so much more fun and
believable or I don't know yeah just a
really enjoyable character I mean I love
the voice actor of Finn I never remember
his name or anything like that but like
whoever does his voice does it so well
like Finn is now Finn Finn's not a
character being voiced by someone to me
it's like I see you Finn and I hear him
and he'll say something I'm like aw God
Finn is just so cute when he says blank
hmm and whoever the voice actor is like
he makes Finn when Finn needs to be
serious he pulls it off so well when he
needs to be kind of like cute and
childish he just pulls it off so well
and like this is a prime example of that
where he's just like did he did it do
and you like what he pops up on top it's
like whoop where's my dingus yeah I mean
it's it's very much a little kid
delivery and having fun but at the same
time when he needs to do the heavy
traumatic stuff or really the hardest
when he has to kind of do both like a
dramatic Mobius happening but he has to
say something that is actually funny
when we hear but to him it's very
serious so he has to live it very
serious I mean it's it's
to doing this I think it's especially
tough for you know a kid grantees
growing up and you can do that voice but
uh it's very tough to do and I think we
get a child actor who is growing up and
learning and doing it even better and
better I mean it's always like I guess
always help to my myself like you know
please don't go nuts please don't go and
say my kids still stay a good actor you
know give us a Joseph gordon-levitt or
something keep the talent going because
you know you hate to see good talent
like that just whatever gets eaten up by
Hollywood or that world or whatever so
yeah I hope I just hope the show never
goes off the air because maybe then this
will
strangely enough keep him saying that's
true oh by the way um I was informed and
clarified by the people the wonderful
people in the comment section um Noah
for us growing up when a season ended we
had to wait half a year for another one
did Adventure Time the longest time span
I think it's been between seasons is
about two months really season five like
pretty much just ended season six has
already started up I know yeah I heard
Stephen six just started up I'm ready
given people being like you know cuz
you're you're waiting to that's a watch
them with no no no oh did you want you
told me to continue so I've been
continuing by the way the newest
episodes yeah that's what I heard so
dumb past me no I tried to tell you but
but ya know that's why I'm here I'm here
no wait really really good um but I
never I'm so used to having to wait
extended periods of time before you get
to watch your beloved show again
adventure time man how awesome is that
oh man gotta wait two months darn it
that sucks well especially I mean I
guess made the federal of the Mets and
the animation for the most part looks
pretty easy to do I mean a lot of those
backgrounds get pretty detailed you know
the designs but yeah I don't know that
cuz I've always watched it on DVD you
know with you but I never knew it like
they came across that quickly moving
about that quickly so no that's
impressive that's very impressive so for
when they because they were bringing it
up during when we're talking about the
cliffhanger and all that so in a sense
it's not really that much of a
cliffhanger how we used to
look at cliffhangers as kids mm-hmm
where something happened we literally
had to wait a half a year before we
found out what happened on the edge of
our seats this is just oh the Lich
happens you wait about a month boom you
figure out what's going on so it's not
as traumatizing I guess well I was gonna
say to with you know show so many shows
now we're just getting more and more you
know a technical and a lot more work as
being put into member usually getting
out shorter episodes and I shorter uh
less amount of episodes but like they'll
have a little break like Walking Dead
had a mid-season finale and they'll have
like a few months and then get back to
the show loss did the same thing because
they're so expensive and they take so
much time to make um they're just going
to you Cairo because the UK's been doing
that forever well yeah but they just do
like what ten episodes a season
something
it's depends on the show a lot of times
it's mainly twelve
sometimes it's six sometimes it's twelve
doctor who does a bit more but then
they'll have like a special here and
there but yeah they'll have like
midseason breaks where you can just kind
of chill out and then booth comes back
on you know they the u.s. seems to be
following that format now yeah which I
mean it seems for the really big hit
shows they're kind of like well if we
have more time to work on it it'll you
know hopefully the project will be
better so and it seems to be working so
um but yes I'd like to say uh or
apologize that yeah we're old farts and
we're used to having to wait for you
know seasons to finish up or start up
again so sorry you kids got it so good
I kind of do but then again we like the
show so that's true um damn you for
making things better
Jeff Nardo are my cats at the window
just go I'm sure Mike can catch it don't
bring him into this video he's - Cameron
up yeah no I liked it it was a fun fun
episode just yeah I know it's a
throwaway episode baguettes its own
separate entity yeah I mean one might
seem like these characters again I mean
it's you know you know what it makes me
think of ghosts in the show the series
is called of a series okay in the series
it's called stand alone complex there
are standalone episode
but the whole thing is complex but
that's literally what it is
there are mythology episodes in there
just the standalone episodes but that's
why it's called standalone complex and
that's kind of what this is you've got
the overarching stuff which is the
complex and the standalone ones like
this does it have any squirrels